what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are finally picking back up
with the events of Earth X and we we
basically wrap it up we are finished
with Earth X at the end of this video
and it's been one heck of a ride I mean
honestly this was just a philan story
until we could get close enough to
continue our videos on like Thanos and
you know the events leading it's like
Infinity Gauntlet and so on and so forth
I'm still on the fence about whether or
not I'm gonna do universe X and paradise
X but with Earth X we basically pick up
following the arrival of Galactus and
this was the huge revelation that had
basically come out of the events of
Earth X that all the superheroes that
existed on earth the entire history of
the earth that it was all basically
preordained or at least as close to
preordained as you can get that the
Celestials essentially travel around
from planet to planet they plant their
seed inside of a planet so that it can
give birth to a new celestial and in
order to make sure that the planet stays
safe the Celestials in turn modify the
genes of whatever citizens or whatever
you know species is the dominant species
on that planet so that they will develop
superpowers and the idea is that like
any species trying to maintain itself
trying to ensure its own survival
they'll face off against any external
threat that would try to destroy the
world
all the while never realizing that
they're actually protecting a celestial
seed what this means is that when the
celestial seed is born the earth will be
destroyed now something that I want you
guys to notice here is that Galactus
begins the process of constructing his
world of our advice where the Celestials
attempt to try to stop the lactis it's
really more of like putting up force
fields things like that but the
Celestials don't actually try to kill
Galactus or at least they don't
initially and the reason for this is
remember it's all about balance in Earth
X Galactus basically travels around the
cosmos and consumes life-sustaining
planets or planets capable of supporting
life because that's where the Celestials
will plant their seeds and it's just
designed to basically keep a celestial
population from running out of control
from basically dominating the entirety
of an individual universe and so because
of the fact that Galactus is going
through and essentially destroying the
celestial seed inside of the planet the
Celestials in turn begin to start to
launch an attack against Galactus now
there are a couple of things and I want
you guys to also notice too for example
you've got the Silver Surfer but you
also have you also have shallow ball now
shallow ball of course is basically the
girlfriend of Norrin Radd before he
became the Silver Surfer and he had
essentially sacrificed his life and
became a silver surfer in order to
spares
in law his home planet but again Earth X
feeds into the nature of Galactus and
the Celestials and so what this man is
Galactus didn't just show up to zenn-la
one day for the purpose of just
consuming it because he was just really
really hungry one day it was basically
the whole idea that he showed up here
because there was a celestial seed in
sides in law and so with the Silver
Surfer said find spare my planet I will
become your new Herald the result is
that that's exactly what happened now of
course Chalobah ended up becoming an
equivalent to Silver Surfer and we're
not really told exactly how that happens
in this story but regardless of the
scenario she's basically on par with a
silver surfer here and it's cool because
the idea of the Celestials finally
intervening and beginning the process of
trying to basically destroy Galactus and
ensure the survival of this celestial
seed comes when Galactus destroys one of
the Celestials but something else would
also want you guys to notice here is
that read is kind of in awe but he's
also harboring a bit of a secret because
where he sort of analyzed this whole
situation musing to himself talking to
x51 one of the things he says is that
Galactus is a compassionate being the
problem with this is that Reed Richards
didn't realize this until it was too
late and when the question is asked what
do you mean by that Reed says I turned
Galactus into a star and what that means
is that the Galactus here is not the
original Galactus and that begs the
question who is it and so that's why
this is so cool that's that's that's why
I've been dying to do this reveal I've
been dying to do this reveal for so long
because it is so amazing now the other
half of this is remember loki had
basically discovered that the Asgardians
are essentially beings who were formless
they were just kind of shape-shifting
organisms that existed out there one day
and then when they first encountered
humanity humanity viewed them as like
Norse gods and that's where the
Asgardians came from that's why we have
Thor and Odin but the idea that that
loki had realized this whole situation
that the Asgardians are not inherently
as guardians meant that he was able to
rally the entire cause because what he
said is if the humans on earth die then
we will basically die in our current
form and so because of this the Asgard
has basically intervened and begin the
process of jumping into the conflict
against the Celestials but the fact
remains Reed actually takes off from
watching the Celestials basically engage
in battle with one another and
essentially goes back to Medusa
basically saying look the whole reason
why Inhumans returned to Earth in the
first place was to look for the son of
Black Bolt
and Medusa so they can in turn marry the
daughter of Quicksilver and crystal the
issue is that they've been looking
for the you know for the Sun the entire
time but haven't been able to find him
now earlier in these videos we talked
about the Black Knight that basically
stood alongside Captain Britain and we
didn't know who the Black Knight was and
he was never addressed that's when we
basically learned this is the son of
Black Bolt this is where he's been the
entire time he's been hiding under
everyone's nose he's basically just been
perceived as the heir of Captain Britain
should Britain ever fall and it's not
she the perfect idea just hiding in
plain sight but who's ever going to
guess - the Black Knight standing
alongside Britain's only real remaining
super hero is the heir to the inhuman
royal family so it is pretty smart not a
great big huge thing but it's just
designed to kind of wrap up the inhuman
plot that was going on with regards to
this story but again jumping back to
Galactus the cool thing is that the
Celestials cannot destroy Galactus I
mean they could if they wanted to but it
would it would upset the natural balance
of things and what this means is that if
Galactus were to be destroyed by the
Celestials in response to the fact that
he's been destroying Celestials
themselves then most likely what would
happen is you would have like The Living
Tribunal up here and the linee tribunal
would say this does not work Galactus
represents cosmic balance Galactus has
to exist and then most likely the Living
Tribunal would reconstitute Galactus and
we would be right back at square one
again and so the result is that the
cosmic balance is maintained the
Celestials ultimately take off and even
then it's not a great big huge deal
right like this is one planet in a
single solar system in a singular galaxy
in an infinitely expanding universe
losing one celestial seed is by no means
the end of all things earth is
essentially irrelevant and the greater
cosmos of what is the universe because
that what we end up having is Reed
Richards who travels back to New York
and essentially like reaches out to
Galactus and basically calls out his
name and this is when we learned Reed
was the one who summoned Galactus and
the reason why Reed was able to summon
Galactus across the cosmos is because
Reed Richards didn't have like a device
he didn't have an artifact
he didn't shout the name Galactus what
he shouted was the name of Franklin and
that's when we find out Franklin
Richards is the new Galactus now this is
insane this is cool but again this is
one of those moments where Marvel kind
of built on this later on Jonathan
Hickman doing the whole like you know
Fantastic Four run and the idea that
like future Franklin Richards powers
were equal to the power of Galactus when
they had that huge conversation at the
end of the story and Galactus basically
said like we'll stand at the end of all
things it was kind of predicated on a
lot of the earth X stuff that was done
but the whole idea here is that Franklin
doesn't really remember himself being
Franklin Richards
sees himself as Galactus and he operates
as Galactus Franklin realizes that he
was called Franklin and he finds it kind
of strange but Reach is kind of like
well you know I just called you by the
name of my son because you know I love
my son but he doesn't really explicitly
address Galactus and say you are
Franklin Richards you are my son instead
it's you just remind me of my son I mean
it is Franklin but it is kind of cool
that the son of read the reality-warping
son of Reid would have sinned to the
level of godhood because in truth it's
the most natural evolution for his
character I would imagine if Galactus
were ever destroyed it would make sense
that like Franklin would take his place
but what you end up having is the
celestial seed destroyed inside the
earth by Galactus Galactus this
basically takes off says we will not see
each other again this will be the end of
us following this things actually wrap
up pretty quickly what you end up having
is x51 machine man basically realizing
the truth behind who watch you The
Watcher that not only was he blinded by
Black Bolt notif or Black Bolt to
basically hide his actions when he had
initially left the planet Earth and
given everybody powers to the Terrigen
mists but what's also been going on is
they watch The Watcher can only really
know what's going on in earth by hearing
everything that's going on and so
essentially what happens is Machine Man
comes along and basically says like your
race was designed for the purpose of
watching things but you guys are
apathetic
over the course of your entire existence
you've watched the Celestials plant seed
in worlds create life on that world or
metal in the old metal with the life on
that world and then in turn watch that
world grow watch those you know species
kind of reach maturity and then watch
the Celestials show up destroy
everything and then give birth to a new
celestial and just repeat the same thing
time and time again your entire
existence has been nothing but the sole
purpose of just watching things be
destroyed that's kind of the cool thing
with Machine Man because what he says is
to do nothing in the face of such evil
that is truly heinous
but notices it's almost like it's almost
kind of like you know the idea of like
good and evil exists here but in this
scenario I would say a dozen I mean it
doesn't make any sense to say like you
are evil because of a inherent you know
natural Drive that you as an organism
has the idea of Celestials planting
their seeds in a planet and then
manipulating the genes of that species
in order for them to protect the planet
and then in turn having that planet
destroyed when it when the celestial is
born that's no more evil than like the
wind blowing they play a role in the
universe they are a fundamental force of
the universe good and evil don't really
apply here and that's the cool thing is
because what this is designed to hit
home at is despite the fact that
fifty-one machine-man has watched all of
this happen and despite the fact that he
has all this experience and what it
means to like be human and to understand
humans at the end of the day he's not
human because he's trying to apply human
attributes of right and wrong to a
situation that doesn't call for it and
it's not applicable I so because of this
like the whole basis of machine man kind
of adopting these mentalities and then
in turn trying to use them on the
watcher really hits home at the idea
that at the end of the day when it's all
said and done he's no more of a man than
he was when he was first created he's
just walking the paces he's just doing
what people do and that's really about
it and so again for the most part we're
the celestial seed being destroyed
society just kind of reverts back to its
standard standard form in the sense that
you still have people who wage war
against one another but because of the
fact that there was a common threat that
saw the near destruction of all things
that basically people begin to sort of
consolidate and come back down the world
begins to return back to a state of
normalcy form and function of organized
society begin to come back again the
issue with this is that in the middle of
everything
read kind of falls asleep or has a dream
sequence and he's suddenly met by marvel
all the Kree who had died quite some
time ago because of course in Earth X he
had died of cancer just like he did in
the main Marvel Universe and so when is
it happening is Marvel basically says
everything is about to change like
everything that you see going on here
none of its permanent everything is
about to go absolute belly-up the
Celestials were the least of your
concerns things are about to get a whole
lot worse and I'm here to save everyone
but you basically have to protect me you
have to ensure that I will be reborn
into this world and that this birthing
process will go off without a hitch now
in truth he's basically been kind of you
know resurrected so to speak as the
child of hizmet and Adam warlock and so
again it's kind of cool to know that's
gonna happen but what this does is it
sets the stage for the events of
universe X and paradise X this kind of
trilogy of this alternate reality series
of stories they're interesting I mean
again I haven't read them in a long time
so I need to go back and read universe
and paradise but if you guys are
interested in seeing those let me know
down in the comments section I'm sure a
lot of you guys will say yes but if you
guys are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]